what up guys goes and I headed back here
for anime up for what's up everybody and
what do you mean Maori confused no no
that was hyped up man
guys we just got some big news about
Code Geass the Code Geass recap films we
just got the release dates for these
films so we're doing a quick Code Geass
after dark stream to get you guys bad
news as soon as possible goals in what
do you think about this I'm psyched
first night we can see on the screen
here it says 2017 it shows the first
movie second movie third movie so it's
giving us like all the dates the first
one's gonna be October 21st second one's
gonna be do I do Harry and then the
other one's gonna be May I had to do the
math there yeah I'll see you guys you
see where the mouse is pointing that's
the first movie first recap film is
coming on hopefully robbers winning
probably this will actually working out
and yeah and then we have so February 20
18th movie number two and May 2018 movie
number three I know that the second one
is called second movies called rebellion
and the third movies called Emperor
thanks to Otto's translation skills so
we do know that much and I'm excited
usually sometimes these movies add new
stuff and we know this movie these
movies are going to add some new things
but sometimes they just completely
switch it up like with glue and logon
where they added like a whole nother
level to it you know so we'll see if
there are any really significant
additions to these movies but
nevertheless they'll be clues about what
we should expect for the next season
which is exciting yeah and we know 100%
it's been confirmed already that they're
gonna be redoubling these films and that
there's gonna be shooting new scenes so
there is gonna be new footage we
received a quick trailer sort of teaser
if we go through the website here we can
see a quick teaser for the new films
however I did not see any new footage in
this team we get a lot of plans yeah
like if you guys check this out you'll
see just kind of like flashes familiar
scenes though to the
we've already seen we did not I did not
see anything new here it's only a few
seconds but still men the hype bro the
hype like look at this yeah look like
we're it's like 12 o'clock where we are
and we're like we just got news that
we're like yo I gotta go live with this
information let you guys know
yeah it's midnight but you know there's
always time for code geass and you know
sometimes like a teaser trailer like I
just bare minimum bones like you know
gets the job done just keeps us excited
waiting for more yeah I don't know yeah
and this is by the way this is what's
what happened at the end of that
countdown we made a news video this week
talking about that the co Geass official
Twitter account has been making a
countdown for the last seven days and
now after the countdown finally expired
today we got this news release dates for
all three films we've been waiting for
this since November of last year's you
guys and now the release dates are
finally here and my question is are we
gonna be getting some news for the
actual sequel the so called season 3
code yes season 3 anytime soon I really
hope that this is the beginning of the
news for that I see so we don't know
when that's gonna come out either even
later 2018 maybe 2019 but whatever at
least we're getting some updates we're
getting some progress here
so I can't wait like they're definitely
had time to do this right do this well
and I think it's gonna be you know a
smash hit I think it's gonna be just as
good if not like better hype wise that
cookie is r1 it could be a sorry yeah
I'm excited to see the animation style
I'm excited to see I want to see the new
scenes because the yeah I felt like the
the teaser that we had so far
the teaser pv for season 3 or the sequel
had good animation it was like still the
same spirit it's like read a little bit
better
yeah a little bit better so I liked it
I'm definitely down for that I'm excited
for this I'm hoping we're gonna get some
I was afraid after we didn't hear about
anything about them films since November
of last year I was afraid it wasn't
gonna be anything I thought it was gonna
be all just like oh by the way it's
didn't work out so the fact that the
films are coming they're gonna be airing
in Japanese theaters so right there in
the theaters are gonna be airing October
21st is the first one it gives me hope
that you know the
pipe is still there it's happening
they're also gonna be re airing the
entire anime on Japanese TV as you guys
may or may not know so they're gonna be
reading the entire anime leading up to
the movie releases and yeah it's gonna
be crazy hype I think in Japan and here
outside of Japan for Code Geass
yeah man I'm just trying to keep up with
the chat but pretty much to summarize
all of our most of our people like here
they're excited for Code Geass everyone
is hyped even though it's like you know
midnight but everyone's hyped excited
for this news yeah it's midnight where
we are but it's okay we love it I know a
lot of our fans are in like the
Philippines where it's noon so they're
having a great day you know just chillin
relaxed and happy Friday and so it's
like a nice it's like noon time oh nice
livestream about code yes that would be
pretty cool it does anyone does anyone
in the chat find any other news that we
might have missed because I want to make
sure we cover everything before we sign
off that we have all the news for you
right here animator it says I'm more
hype than Briggs
shut up to the peeps in the chair love
King here representing it's 11 p.m. for
Lou that's 11 p.m. - Urbano for Ivana
it's 9:00 in California yeah he's in
Cali what's up man yeah so that's
awesome that's awesome no like really
like this is amazing we've been waiting
for news for so long and you see like
they have more specific information on
the first movie already like the actual
date or the other ones are more baked
just give us a month but it's gonna be
interesting to see now them come out
hopefully the other ones won't have any
more problems and season 3 will probably
be here you know in the blink of an eye
it'll feel long probably but looking
back on it as probably and yeah by the
way this is the official code yes
Twitter page right now as you guys see
you're looking at they already updated
down dated the official art this is
where they had the whole countdown and
then down now we we have the news the
little teaser everything happening
pretty fast and of course merchandise
they like to sell their merchandise
obviously guys will let you know
definitely as well as something updates
about it but also feel free to fall
my Twitter you can get the information
there as well and by the way of course
here stay tuned to anime or we will keep
you posted for all the news if you're
not subscribed be sure to subscribe hit
the notifications because stuff is
happening we see some images here
they're not yet there we go these are
all new posts from a few minutes ago on
the official Twitter page so yeah man
this just brings back and I just believe
that I'm quite sure all now there's
coach yes I just like today yeah yes our
channel posted all 50 episodes of code
yesterday I'm sure did today because
there are they do they knew about the
countdown and they were like yeah let's
do it guys you know you know we'll be
watching rewatching that I get hyped for
these movies stuff I'm gonna be exciting
definitely check them out yeah see this
was the countdown guys they were going 1
2 3 4 5 6 from from a 7 oh man all Colin
I can't wait it's been too long since I
got like you callin like media yeah eat
it
Oh more combat all I don't know what
this is but I want it I want to buy it
it's like circles thanks it don't give
you a paper printed on it but circles I
love it take my money shut up and take
my money shot up all of these these are
one of those like pins probably or
something glasses look made they're
really like drunk on Geass there's no
like on here there's wine glasses these
are all brand new Pulis guys from only a
few minutes ago bottle says call for
like damn right call him for life yes
yes Valletta baby yeah he switched up
he's not oh I know you know us convoys
how stay loyal
I respect you see two lovers two maleta
is like you know okay again anyone in
the chat if you have any other further
news that we haven't had yet let us know
but from what we know now we other
release dates for all three films and of
course we know that in the past after
the theatrical releases at the end of
each move at the end of a movie we could
we would get huge news about potential
season so I think for sword art online
the recent movie they actually had a big
news at the end of the movie
gonna be another season of sort of our
line am i right I don't know is there
gonna be like that's I believe so so
yeah in anime there is a tradition of
when you have big films at the end of
the film getting big news about things
like sequels so because we know the Cody
s is gonna have a sequel it is very
possible that news is coming at the end
of the first movie so October 21st
also people saying that we're gonna get
Christian Flores saying that we're gonna
get Nina exhale oh cool in part two so
well I make sense that only makes sense
shout out the floor like imagine just
everything we like about Cody s all the
mediums like doubled on crack for season
3 and you know Michael a Dragon Ball
super the creators were just like we
were paying attention we were watching
the anime pour discord and we decided to
just go full meme that would be
impossible
give it be cool if like they're just
actually checking out our channel being
like Oh what do they have to say I'm
both in your moaning yeah it's like your
look at our theories like these guys are
way off what up not so glad you're here
yeah Oh guys that's happening finally
news we knew it's gonna be big with the
countdown like you know there weren't
gonna be like guys alright 37 Imagi like
you sure because by the way we've been
checking the Code Geass official
Japanese website regularly and almost
daily and they have been updating it but
only with new merch so it hasn't been it
hasn't been like any significant news
just like all check out this merchandise
check on this merchandise they were like
Jake Paul and they were Jake Paul in US
but with discount that I was like man it
better not be just new merch and of
course it is new merch we have plenty of
new merch here however we also have news
about the recap film finally about the
recap films yeah hopefully they're given
they're given the money they deserve
this time yeah because you guys know
that when Kobe s first was airing and it
came out it wasn't that popular so they
cut down on the episodes they did they
had trouble with funding so hopefully
now people have discovered what a great
anime this is they're gonna be getting
all that merch money and they're gonna
be making a proper
sequel that my budget say in hindsight
is twenty-twenty right so now they have
clients so I did all popular says if you
guys go to my anime list
the most popular character all time is
lelouch lamperouge Lelouch VI Britannia
so this is the like on the Japanese for
the Japanese what's it called that
magazine new-type yes he was voted as
the number one all-time I believe here
like it was it was there was a pool
taken after the news about yeah which
makes it but he's so sick don't like he
had before the news he was up there I
hate my anime list before the Cody Asche
news and yeah guys I mean that alone
shows you how influential and how
awesome this was like this really this
even though it doesn't always feel like
a mecha anime it was definite like one
of those mecha anime that even non mecha
fans can get it it's one of those few
few ones that can pull it off and just
get mainstream attention I wouldn't be
surprised
hopefully like Netflix doesn't buy it
and then doesn't air it for like the
next four years
yeah the Netflix strategy let's wait
that's why the rights and then release
it all at once after it areas it's like
yeah I'm pretty sure everyone's one
night so else good Netflix is like
everyone everyone split that younger
staff Lex is just lying about what
season they have and the specials
mislabelling stuff and now they're like
not even letting us watch the anime they
bought rights for because they're
waiting for lady like what are they
doing man what are they doing like yeah
you know coast isn't just like what's
called yes yeah okay so I guess so I
guess he too is someone oh man I guess
he too is someone else oh man I never
signed up as like that bro should never
should we show that mousepad
did we already show it definitely did a
sample we've short in the in the blog
but yeah we got a c2 boobie mousepad for
in no clothes but now we don't know what
exactly where it is where are you most
anyway point is we're also buying that
church it's selling like a god Church so
yeah by now murder you just never buy
that church we're blind died whatever
whatever find out hi
I trade and you know what we were like
surely postmaster post-war and that were
like Mass every day bro my god we got
closer today come at you with new closet
every day cuz everyday bro don't forget
subscribe merchant abide by my question
I wish beyond Myrtle don't forget to
keep your colors popping yes especially
if you don't have collars Britannia is
my city what what did he just say
Britannia is my city yes he did yes he
did oh man respect for that
no thank you I was creative thank you
incorporating the world code geass
nicely I feel like if a lot of people
are watching this right now we're in the
room they'll be like Julis yes bro
I mean I'm could be wrong but I hope I'm
right man yeah I like the setup to how
they did the three different colors
loose Rob would like to see like Colin
or c2 in the middle rather than Suzaku
but there you have it Suzaku and then
whoosh again as the Emperor
yeah and that's that's my that's my and
first stuff is just off the chain
Britannia is my city
mm-hmm yeah let's make that a thing guys
Britannia is my city let's make that a
thing and of course if you're a code
geass fan you know that in our discord
server we talk about quote yes all the
time
link in the description check out this
code if you don't know what it is a free
app just like Twitter you just register
and you can use it for chat it's awesome
got a great community over there
including a bunch of the awesome people
in this chat right now and yeah like I
mean I think that's pretty much it for
now we got huge news we will update you
guys as soon as we have any news about
code geass obviously we may even be
releasing code geass contacts so look
out for that
it's comin bro it's coming yeah so
definitely let us know in the comments
once this stream up will let us know
what your thoughts on this news let us
know when you think we're gonna be
getting cold yes season 3 news the
sequel news is it gonna come at the end
of the first movie theatrical trailer 3
a trickle release in October October
21st are we gonna get it is a look at a
leak sooner what's happening
you will be amazing
if at the end of the first film they
show a brand new trailer for the sequel
and then they give us the release day
for the sequel down the first oh yeah
that would be I'm Lea
so they'll be in October hope you know I
hope they do this right they like keep
keep the hype going they give us a
little bit after first went a little
back there second we'll a little bit
after our third movie so it's not all
like I'm waiting for that man but this
is brilliant I feel like lures marketing
for Cody s is doing it right like
splitting up into three movies you know
instead of like two that just Williams
the three and just yeah I think that's I
got to make a lot of money and hopefully
have a lot of money to put into season
three yeah you know I mean they should
definitely have the support worldwide
not just in Japan with worldwide Cody SS
huge popularity over the years it's you
know what's the what's the potential for
like I mean who knows what they're gonna
do maybe if it's like it's an it's super
popular after the first season they may
keep going we don't know we don't know
how it's gonna be are they gonna do they
now have like a definitive ending in my
or are they just gonna be like you know
what this is hot let's keep doing it
make you like ah you know not to Dragon
Ball Z extent but you know if it's five
let's keep going with it we'll see what
happens yeah we got a whole bunch of all
hail Lelouch in the chat man people are
hyped yeah I'd be surprised if they
weren't saying oh and Britannia is my
city Britannia is the city and in also
if you guys know from watching our
videos we have a whole full Code Geass
playlist on our channel yes and we
talked about the world of code yes and
what potential it has for more you know
for sequels spin-offs whatever we talked
about like what might happen and like
the next season we talked about
everything why fools we talked about
everything guys so check out that
playlist if you haven't already
yeah there's so much potential for this
world do you know it's a great world
that they set up to build more more
characters more character development I
can't wait I'm sorry thanks guys for
coming to watch us even if it's late or
early or whatever time it is and be sure
to subscribe if you haven't already
because we'll keep you updated with the
later we will keep you latest news
called yeah he's the notification belt
because sometimes you'll miss you can
miss the news you too
you know how it is but yeah this was
cool this is all the news we have so far
release dates for the three films
October 21st the next the first milk
film is coming out Japan
theaters then February not no exact date
for the third a second film and may 2018
for the third film and hopefully we're
gonna get some actual sequel news soon
maybe a new trailer something I'm
excited for that I'm excited for the
movies I'm excited for news I'm excited
for a potential but anyways guys until
next time see you space cowboys all hail
Lelouch leave a like if you liked this
video